Now to New
York, where
former President
Donald Trump is now invited to testify
before a Manhattan grand jury.
It's all part of their investigation
into alleged
hush money
payments to stormy
Daniels during the 2016 election.
So this is a potential sign
that prosecutors are zeroing
in on an indictment.
Let's turn now to CNN's Chris Cornell.
Carol, what do you know
Well, that's right.
So sources
tell us that
this invitation
was made
to the former president's
lawyers in recent days
to appear before the grand jury.
And this is a sign
that this investigation
is coming to a conclusion
and that a decision
of whether or not to seek an indictment
is likely to happen
more in the next few weeks than months.
You know, we've also seen
a parade of witnesses
going in Kellyanne Conway, Hope Hicks,
you know,
all signals
that this is getting toward
the finish line.
Also today, Michael Cohen went in to meet
with the district attorney's office.
Our cameras caught him.
And let's take a listen
to what he had to say.
I have to applaud
District Attorney Bragg
for giving Donald
the opportunity to come in
and to tell his story.
Now, knowing Donald
as well as I do,
understand that
he doesn't tell the truth.
It's one thing to turn around
and to lie on your untruths, social.
It's another thing to turn around
and lie before a grand jury,
which I don't suspect
that he's going to be coming.
Now, sources
tell us that among the charges
that prosecutors are weighing,
they relate to the hush money payment.
But hush money payment
itself is not a crime.
So they're looking at how this payment
was reimbursed.
Remember, Donald Trump
signed those checks to Michael Cohen.
So prosecutors are looking at
how the Trump Organization
accounted for that
in their books and records.
So they're looking at possible
falsifying business record charge,
which is a misdemeanor,
or falsifying records in
order to commit or conceal another crime.
In this case,
that could be campaign
finance violations now.
I mean, this is not an easy case.
It's a novel legal theory.
And Trump's
lawyers will certainly have
a lot of defenses
that they'll throw up at this.
We spoke to one of the attorneys,
Joe Tacopina.
And in a statement, he said, the D.A.
and the former D.A.
have been scouring every aspect
of President Trump's personal life
and business affairs
for years in search of a crime
and needs to stop.
This is simply not
what our justice system is about.
And as we know, Trump
is facing a number
of other legal challenges,
other criminal investigations
having to do with the 2020
election, both in Fulton
County, Florida
and at the Justice Department level,
as well as the handling
of classified documents.
So certainly a lot coming to a head
for the former president.
This one looks like
it could be the first move
a long time coming to.
Chris, Cornell, thank you.
Well, let's bring in legal
analyst Elliot Williams.
So, Elliott,
the president has been offered
an opportunity to testify.
Does that the former president,
does that signal
that an indictment, in your
view, is likely
and signals that one could be coming now?
New York is one of the jurisdictions,
and there are any number across
the United States
that give defendants
and operative or potential defendants
an opportunity to come in
and make their case prior
to charges being raised.
Now, sometimes people can use that
as an opportunity
to sort of say, you know, look,
I might have engaged in those actions,
but here's why.
And there's a legal basis
for why I did them and so on.
The problem is
that it's fraught with peril
to do that,
because, number one,
he would have to waive
what's called his immunity.
So any statement
he made could be used against him.
And number two,
he can't control the questions
that he's asked.
So for any number of reasons,
we're probably not likely to see him
come in and testify here.
So Kerry described this as a novel
legal theory.
Does novel, in this case,
equal week case?
What's your take on on the approach here?
That's an excellent question, Victor.
And look at the way
our law works in this country
is that you bring cases
based on what has come before.
And there are some cases that simply
the situation hasn't
presented itself before.
And it's legally complex.
And the backup cameras point.
It's sort of a case within a case.
Within a case,
you would have to prove first
that there were hush money payments,
but then
not just that the payments happened,
that they happened in
knowing furtherance
of another criminal offense.
So it's not just
writing a hush money
check to to quiet down
somebody who might have
embarrassing facts about you.
It's because, you know,
you're violating campaign finance law.
That's never been done.
And that's a big leap
and a big step
for what
ultimately could be a misdemeanor
or a very, very small penalty.
That doesn't even Gary
doesn't require
is it required to carry jail time.
So, yes, they can do it.
And there's certainly
a path to it happening.
But it's not
particularly straightforward legally.
Yeah.
Talk more about the potential charges,
because it could range anything
from a misdemeanor to a felony.
So in terms of sentences
that they may carry
what's on the horizon here?
Sure.
Starting with the felony.
Even if so, let's pretend
that the prosecutors
even are able to establish
all these hush money
payments were made to suppress
or to suppress
or commit a campaign finance violation.
Even that has a maximum
four year sentence.
And nobody gets a four year sentence
for a campaign finance violation,
and it's not even required
to send them to jail.
So it would be
maybe for probation
or something like that.
That's a lot of legal wrangling
to go through for
somebody that may never end up
going to jail in the first place. So.
And then if that doesn't happen,
it's just a misdemeanor,
which doesn't even carry
less than a year in prison.
So there's just not significant penalties
that even under the best of circumstances
would come from this case.
Let's talk about Michael Cohen.
We just heard from him
he was there at the Manhattan DA's
office today.
A source tells CNN
he'll be back there Monday.
And it's been pointed out that, yes, he's
a convicted felon.
He's a proven liar.
But he he lied on behalf of Trump.
Right.
How problematic is that for this case
and how much of the case
really hinges upon Michael Cohen's word?
Sure.
Well, based
on what's
publicly available
right now,
the strongest evidence they have
is Michael Cohen's word.
And I want to be clear.
He testified under oath before Congress
as to the facts of this
of this case here.
So that itself is powerful.
Evidence is under oath.
It's more and so on.
The simple fact is
he is a convicted felon
based on honesty issues.
And any defense attorney
is going to hammer him
and hammer
a prosecution here
over the fact that the star witness
has serious credibility issues.
So, you know,
when Karen mentioned earlier
in the segment
that they were bringing
in a number of other witnesses
and trying to get other evidence,
I think that's to insulate
around the fact
that the evidence that you have
and Michael Cohen just isn't that strong.
He might be telling the truth,
but he's got credibility issues.
And in court,
all that matters
is can a jury
believe
the evidence is presented to them?
And when they have a witness
who will himself
admit on the stand
that he's got a felony conviction,
it's just hard to believe them in
order to convict.